Microsoft has announced plans
to acquire LinkedIn
for $26.2 billion,
making history
as the most anyone has ever paid
for a list of people
without jobs.
-(laughter)
-Now,
hopefully,
Microsoft does something
about all the e-mails sent to me
asking me to join LinkedIn
even after I've opted out!
Every single time.
LinkedIn is basically
"It follows, the Web site."
(laughter)
And I imagine
Microsoft just bought it
so they could (bleep)
stop getting e-mails
from LinkedIn, as well.
-(applause)
-And...
Also...
Extremely...
extremely ironic and sad,
because Clippy, the paper clip,
has been a LinkedIn power user
since being laid off in 2008.
Tough times for Clippy.
Oh, no.
-(laughter) -Oh. That's too bad.
-Oh, Clippy.
(in high-pitched voice):
I can stretch my body
and do a reach-around
for five more.
Microsoft is calling it a deal
between the world's
leading professional cloud
and the world's
leading professional network
which is what I plan
on telling my children
to help them fall asleep.
Comedians,
what's an even worse merger?
-Horatio.
-Oh, my penis and my zipper.
(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-Yes.
That is, uh...
that's the other LinkedIn.
Points for you.
Nick Swardson.
Uh, Ecstasy
and my family reunion.
-HARDWICK: All right.
-(laughter, applause)
-Points. Mary Lynn.
-The Catholic Church and Grindr.
-(laughter and groaning)
-HARDWICK: Well, I don't know.
-Wait a minute.
Think about it. -(applause)